[Musica]
Innanzitutto Buonasera a tutti Io sono
Sara
parrucchiera
Scommetto che in questa sala se non
tutti però gran parte Andiamo dal
parrucchiere dal barbiere Magari andiamo
a fare la classica tinta la classica
piega il classico taglio ma una cosa di
cui son sicura sia per gli uomini che
per le donne è che quando andiamo dal
parrucchiere entriamo che siamo un certo
tipo di persona ed educiamo che siamo un
po' trasformati persone nuove forse ho
dovuto dire anche più fresche andiamo
dai nostri amici dai nostri parenti e
chiediamo com'è Hai visto il mio nuovo
taglio ti piace ci sentiamo quasi
trasformate
infatti c'è una frase che ho sempre
trovato molto interessante e questa
frase dice una donna che cambia taglio
di capelli è una donna che sta per
cambiare la propria vita
strano è però scommetto che
effettivamente potete confermarmi quello
che vi ho detto prima giusto che ci
sentiamo persone più fresche
e se vi dicessi che invece si sono
persone che dal parrucchiere non ci
vogliono più andare
e se vi dicessi che ci sono persone che
ad esempio una ragazza mi contattò e mi
disse che è andata per talmente tanti
anni dal parrucchiere che i capelli
distrutti
e invece un'altra una mamma mi ha
contattato e mi disse che non vuole che
la figlia senta quell'urgenza quella
necessità che ha sempre sentito lei di
andare dal parrucchiere per tutta la
vita per stare bene con se stessa
un'altra ancora quando mi contattò mi
disse Guarda sarà bello il parrucchiere
Eh mi piace mettere le parrucche mi
piace fare le treccine però sono stanca
di sottopormi a questa trasformazione
Sara non ce la faccio più Voglio
evolvermi sono pronta per una vera e
propria evoluzione
prima di spiegarvi però di che cosa sto
parlando Guardiamo insieme la
definizione di evoluzione possiamo
vedere che evoluzione è sviluppo
graduale e completo ma ciò che
preferisco in questa definizione la
parola svolgimento proprio come ad
esempio svolgere il rotolo di un papiro
quando svolgiamo un rotolo di un papiro
cosa facciamo Apriamo un qualcosa che è
stato chiuso in precedenza
ad esempio
disimparare per imparare
spogliarsi per rivestirsi
lasciar andare per riprendere
E che cosa hanno in comune tutte queste
azioni
che il primo atto la prima azione è una
sorta di liberazione lasciar andare un
qualcosa togliersi un peso
e di che peso sto parlando
per farvelo capire vi racconterò della
mia evoluzione personale della mia
storia e voglio tornare indietro a
quando ero bambina con voi
No non vi preoccupate non c'è niente di
brutto eh di quando ero bambina L'unica
cosa che era una bambina felice mi
ricordo se penso mi divertivo mi piaceva
un sacco andare a scuola Ero un uragano
facevo Note su note Vi giuro
e mi ricordo che pensavo solo a giocare
a guardare la televisione e c'era un
giorno che preferivo durante tutta la
settimana e quel giorno era il sabato
perché il sabato finalmente alla tv
vedevo loro
mi ricordo che ero lì come una bambina
non so se vi ricordate il programma Top
of the Pops Ok tutti artisti americani
mi sedevo davanti alla televisione e le
imitavo non amavo Beyoncé amavo Kelly
Anche se quella che è diventata famosa e
mi ricordo che i loro video mi
prendevano talmente tanto che mi alzavo
ballavo mi divertivo mi sentivo una di
loro
Ma sapete perché in realtà il sabato era
il mio giorno preferito
non perché c'era le Destiny Child Forse
era una scusa ma oggi posso dirvi che il
sabato era il mio giorno preferito
perché durante tutti gli altri giorni
della settimana non vedevo nessuno in
televisione che era come me
Eh sì andava a scuola pure Mi guardavo
in giro i miei compagni non erano come
me
e il sabato invece era il mio giorno
mi divertivo
e mi sentivo talmente tanto una di loro
che chiudevo gli occhi mi sentivo nei
video ero lì ero lì però mancava una
cosa
quei capelli che svolazzavano al vento
coi capelli che si muovevano confluenza
erano stupendi e io dovevo per forza
averli
E se io penso a quando da piccolina
Andavo dal parrucchiere il mio processo
era solo una ed era sempre lo stesso
Crema lisciante
chimico
crosta alla testa
quell'odore di ammoniaca
se ci penso ancora ad oggi quella cosa
mi fa male perché era veramente
sofferenza era sofferenza pure
e se ci penso la cosa più assurda Sapete
qual era
che i capelli non uscivano mai lisciare
e uscivano così Cosa c'era di liscio in
tutto ciò
Eppure
lo ripetevo sempre perché almeno
avevo i capelli come i miei compagni di
classe almeno avevo i capelli come le
Destiny Child
e voi vi chiederete Com'è possibile che
una bambina come mai una mamma
obbliga una bambina a sottoporsi a tutto
questo a tutta questa sofferenza per
arrivare a un risultato che alla fine
non è altro che un'illusione
perché mia mamma stessa lo faceva
Perché le mie zie le mie cugine tutte le
persone che avevano questo tipo di
capello lo facevano
per noi era la normalità
e la cosa buffa è che come potete notare
questo tipo di capello non può diventare
liscio per via strutturale è impossibile
eppure questa era la normalità
o forse meglio dire un circolo vizioso
Allora crescendo andando a scuola
volendo sperimentare anche un po' con la
mia immagine ho deciso di partire da qui
da zero
alle superiori Mi sono rasata tutti i
capelli e vi dirò È stata una bella
Liberazione basta treccine basta chimico
e per la prima volta vi posso dire che
mi sono sentita a me stessa
più crescevano i miei capelli e più mi
rendevo conto che in realtà i miei
capelli non erano un problema perché mi
sentivo bellissima nessuno mi giudicava
nessuno mi faceva sentire sbagliata io
potevo uscire dalla porta di casa con
quei capelli
Il problema è che 0
più crescevano i miei capelli più mi
sono resa conto che 0 era anche il
numero di riferimenti che io avevo
Perché i parrucchieri offrivano
semplicemente i soliti servizi crema
lisciante treccine parrucche e in più la
reperibilità dei prodotti
fino in America dovevo andare America
Africa doveva uscire dall'Italia perché
qua i prodotti per i capelli come me non
c'erano
Però io ho una grande dote ho tanti
difetti Eh però un preso ce l'ho
ed è anche lo stesso nome che uso sui
social media ed è la perseveranza Io
sono molto perseverante se mi metto una
cosa in testa io non mi fermo allora ho
imparato e sono riuscita a far fiorire i
miei capelli
i miei capelli sono fioriti e io stavo
talmente bene con me stessa che ho
deciso di utilizzare i miei canali
Social per condividere un po' no far
vedere i miei bellissimi capelli in
realtà all'inizio e ho fatto il mio
primo video
quando ho fatto il mio primo video ho
notato una cosa sin da subito
che quel riferimento che a me mancava
Quando ho iniziato ad abbracciare la mia
identità a voler conoscere il mio
capello mancava tantissime persone
e tantissime persone hanno iniziato a
scrivermi a contattarmi Sara cosa usi
Sara Come fai anche vorrei avere i
capelli come i tuoi voglio smettere di
fare lisciante voglio smettere di fare
così cosa ma io potevo aiutare fino a un
certo punto Perché i mezzi ad esempio
non c'erano
Ma come vi ho detto prima ho tanti
difetti ma ho preso ce l'ho ed è la
perseveranza
e la perseveranza mi ha dato modo di
riuscire ad aprire il mio marchio di
prodotti principalmente dedicate ai
capelli afro
e Voi direte Che bella storia Wow Brava
complimenti Eh sì magari
Perché sì le persone erano contente di
piacevano i prodotti bene Abbiamo dei
prodotti per noi
però mi sono resa conto che tantissime
persone nonostante avessero i mezzi non
riuscivano ad uscire da quel circolo
vizioso
troppe persone non riuscivano a far
fiorire a riprendere in mano la propria
identità nonostante avessero tutto ciò
che serviva davanti a loro
Allora effettivamente
Io mi sono resa conto che
sapete di che cosa ha bisogno queste
persone
di un riferimento pieno al 100%, ma
soprattutto di una motivazione una
motivazione vera Allora io così ho
iniziato a dargli la grinta no a fargli
capire ragazzi guardate che pure io ci
sono passata e vi dico alla fine è bello
stare bene con se stessi alla fine è una
cosa positiva una cosa bellissima
Allora dando la motivazione il giorno
dopo giorno mi sono guadagnata un
soprannome e hanno iniziato a chiamarmi
coach
e all'inizio non capivo No perché dicevo
non alleno nessuno coach di cosa
Però effettivamente se ci penso
il corso cosa fanno ti allenano
fisicamente quindi nella parte esterna
ed è quello che facevo perché vi insegno
vi do anche i mezzi Ottimo ma il corso
soprattutto ti danno la motivazione di
tornare il giorno dopo ed allenarti
ancora
Questo era il mio vero lavoro
infatti
vi ricordate la ragazza che vi ho detto
che dopo anni e anni e anni di
parrucchiera aveva una situazione
disastrosa per lei era diventata una
vera e propria sofferenza benissimo
come coach mio lavoro esterno è stato
questo bello sto ricresciuti i capelli
non aveva quasi più niente in questo
caso lo piscia all'attrazione
sono i Fioriti
Ma dato che come vi ho detto all'inizio
quando una donna cambia taglio di
capelli e perché è pronta per un
cambiamento interno
il suo cambiamento interno L'ha fatto Ha
avuto il coraggio proprio come ho fatto
io di partire da zero e lei ad esempio
si sente libera e fiera dei suoi capelli
afro Ovvero della sua identità
questo messaggio È lunghissimo ma vi
estrapolo due o tre due frasi anzi
Ciao Sara Non so da dove incominciare è
da una settimana che cerco di
raccogliere tutte le parole per
descrivere questo grande percorso dei
miei capelli ma soprattutto interiore
proprio perché come ci siamo detti sin
dall'inizio Quando una donna fa un
cambiamento esterno in realtà è Specchio
di un cambiamento interno
Ti giuro Sara che ci sono un sacco di
altre cose belle che vorrei dirti ma non
ci sono parole per ringraziarti ti rendi
conto di ciò che stai facendo della
grandissima rivoluzione che stai
mettendo in atto e io qua non direi
rivoluzione
Io semplicemente quello che ho fatto
Ho preso in mano Forse inconsciamente me
stessa
ho deciso di essere quello che sono
ho deciso di essere libera a livello
interiore per essere anche libera a
livello esterno
e ho deciso soprattutto di mettermi in
gioco al 100% di evolvere e nella mia
evoluzione sono riuscita a aiutare
veramente tantissime persone
tanto che io vorrei lasciarvi con questa
frase che non abbiate paura di evolvere
perché quel cambiamento potrebbe essere
motivo di una bellissima scoperta e non
parlo della semplice della semplice
scoperta di avere dei bellissimi capelli
No assolutamente no ma della scoperta di
essere voi stessi perché viviamo in un
mondo dove le influenze Non ci
accorgiamo Ma sono talmente tante che è
davvero facile perdersi e non essere in
grado di esprimersi di di essere di non
aver paura di essere quando invece la
scoperta più bella la cosa più bella è
veramente essere se stessi e uscire
dalla porta del parrucchiere
essendo se stessi Grazie
posso andare
[Applauso]